[Music]
oh it's about to start you ready ready
popcorn buddy nachos cheese root beer
with red licorice straw right here
maybe it's time we made our new movie
good idea scoob but first we need a
trailer oh can you do the trailer guy
voice hmm well let me give it a shot
in the world destroyed by evil
discover the epic origin story
the greatest team of heroes
in the history
of mystery
[Music]
nailed it
[Music]
hey
this mangy strays coming with me he's
not a stray okay then what's his name
his name's
scooby middle name doobie last name
you said that we would always be
without you i feel lost
i'm fred this is velma hi and that's
daphne hey i'm shaggy and this is scooby
doo nice to meet you
[Music]
shaggy and scooby were taken
do you realize where we are no look
around man the clean modern aesthetic
the cool blue color palette we're in
mikey falcon fury did you say ikea nope
i said falcon terry just like you
maybe this can lead us to scooby and
shaggy trace amounts of mustache oil 12
year old scotch
is the bad guy my dad
[Music]
happy birthday mr adult man oh my
god
what was dad like his beard was scratchy
he had a goofy laugh i wish i'd met him
i have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard staff
i wrote this spell so i could see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life he wanted to meet you more
than anything
bully tooth of zedar how did you i don't
know it just started
hang
on
dad
stood up bart dad you are in your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean corey she's
over there quick somebody help me these
griffin nuggets were supposed to go out
minutes ago that's the man's accord
you guys are in trouble big time get in
the vehicle i'm escorting you home i'm
giving you to the count of three
uh okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
i'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry i told them
about the map i told them about the gym
i told them about the curse huh i forgot
to tell them about the cars the what
your boys are in grave danger
hold on
[Applause]
how are your boys doing
oh no
we're dead we're dead we're dead not
great
[Applause]
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this i believe in you
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
yes you do
i'm on my way boys just stay out of
trouble
[Music]
[Music]
i love my life
i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
[Music]
ready
hello little snail what's your name
scary huh do you want to be friends
me too
[Music]
mapped
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends go on dangerous quests
[Music]
with all new faces
hello call me sage good night i'm made
out of sage and i am a sage so it works
out pretty well i'm patrick my name
means toaster in celtic pretty sure it
doesn't the most amazing places the lost
city of atlantic city boy i hope we
don't lose focus look i wouldn't worry
about us losing
ice cream
and a hero let it ride
you can bet on put it on l
patrick that's not an l that's a seven
seven starts with an l
oh that's weird
the spongebob movie sponge on the run
this
oh i love your sense of irony patrick
thank you
i love my sense of ironing too
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name
[Music]
is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even
is shaking on a daily
hey remember that one basis we died on
our table
i found this in my living room
killer replica
a replica of what
a ghost trap
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died
my mom says we're just here to pick
through the rub love's life
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
you're gathered here today to join b and
thomas in holy matrimony you're taking
this so well he's a good man you hated
this guy we've grown very close
welcoming a new parent not that close a
father father father
no you're not my father
peter peter the ring right sorry
are you the author it's really the
rabbit story i just wrote it down look
dad it's peter rabbit oh i hate that i'm
the face of this he's a little naughty
what are you peter that depends who's
asking
peter stay out of trouble told you he
has it in for me he was talking to all
of us i'm talking to you peter
specifically stay out of trouble trouble
trouble
if that's who they think i am
maybe i'd be better off without them
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
what are you looking at goody goody
you're gonna turn me in i'm no goody
goody apparently i'm a baddie batter
get out of
pain is your here
peter rabbit yeah i was best friends
with your dad my name's barnabas you're
a fierce bad rabbit just like him where
are the rabbits back in their borough
snug is a bug in a rug i'm gonna live
forever
[Music]
yeah i can
[Music]
and that's why adults shouldn't do kids
stuff
[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers
and the arrowhead is the key to
unlocking it
hello i just wanted you to know this has
been mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruises you can take
in the amazon this one is undoubtedly
the cheapest
but also the most thrilling heads up
coming through
out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the back side of water
steve's wonder of the world
we're headed up river to blagramas de
cristo we must secure our travel come on
hello not a good time my brother and i
are looking for passage up river please
go away
i have a lot of money
if you believe in legends you should
believe in curses too
you're gonna beg me to turn back well i
look forward to disappointing you
ten thousand to bring you there alive
dead it's fifteen thousand
why should i pay more dead
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
i cannot win you booked the river cruise
and you can't swim
the price just went up
what would you want to be known for on
earth
we only have a short time on this planet
you want to become the person that you
were born to be
don't waste your time on all the junk of
life what am i doing
spin your precious hours doing what will
bring out the real you
[Music]
the brilliant passionate you
[Applause]
that's ready to contribute something
meaningful and to this world
i got the gig i really need a haircut
today man can you fit me in whoa whoa
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
hello
so what do you want to be remembered for
probably for
doing this funny cowboy dance
[Music]
great
[Applause]
our world
has never been in more danger
[Music]
human greed
is what drove us underground all those
years ago
to escape from your
rapacious appetite
[Music]
i warn you boy
there's no way
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
[Music]
no you will believe
ultimus fell
[Music]
the yukon is a dangerous place
never know what's coming
i came up here because i
didn't want to be around anyone
and then i met buck
was a dog
like no other
you've been spoiled
[Music]
and he'd suffered
[Music]
but he could not be broken
i don't know where you came from but i
know where you are now
welcome to the last place on the earth i
should let him have a minute
doesn't look like he's ever seen snow
before
how do you feel about an adventure
beyond all maps
we could go
you and i
where no one's ever been before
[Music]
see what's out there
[Music]
i'm glad you're enjoying this
i never saw him believe in anything
as much as he believes in you
[Music]
what do you say book
adventure of a lifetime
he was sleeping for two days
in my bed
i am christmas flint
human female
i think you'd like me
i think you'd want to be my friend
dad i think i could be part alien i sure
as heck hope not i'll worry about your
christmas
good afternoon birdies who's excited for
jamboree
there's something special this year an
opportunity to be a part of science this
is dr prasad all the way from nasa we
are putting together a record of life to
launch into space we will be recording
people at the jamboree raise your hands
if you like to think about outer space
that girls
want to be birdie scout i want to go to
jamboree jamboree's talent show is that
you or it's trash you
would have been good for you to be
around other girls what knows i'll raise
you like one of them hillbillies
joseph we're gonna be birdies i'm not a
girl there's nothing the whole book that
says you have to be
to make a troop we need a minimum of
four scouts
you know what ain't your friend right
yeah i don't know that smash gets to
come too
i wanna help the most poorest struggling
fools the earth yes
eileen the latest to glory you just
setting yourself up for your little
heart to get broke no i set myself up to
change my whole life
they can't be birdies birdies have a
strict quality code my booze our quality
well the only number left in the state
of georgia is zero so welcome troop zero
we all got to win one badge each to go
to jamboree buy my cookies so i could be
a woman of substance have fun puke miss
rayleigh don't you before you get the
money boo y'all suck happy and girls we
ain't got nobody to show us how to be
better be that one for us like jesus
what kind of world would it be if every
strange little girl thought she could
just do whatever she wanted
this is what god gave me to work with
and i'm gonna make it beautiful because
it's mine well we look forward to seeing
what you little girls are made of
uh-huh what is it angel we're made of
organs and tissues
let's fall out
i've comes at you hard you sit it on
fire i'm gonna do nothing half-assed i
don't wanna do anything with half an ass
[Music]
i've been told by many cats about that
legendary place let's go find here
[Music]
what are you doing i'm going to
pizzatopia hats on birds cats can't fly
he's really flying
how can we see that photo
let's see the paraglider photo huh a
parrot
why are you looking for peach topia to
find my mother but it's dangerous here
easy to get in hard to get out you
better run little cat
over there
[Music]
i've gotta find kate i'm going now
no way no way
i'll go you're both useless
[Music]
i have toys stop toys buy two get one
free
get ready almost there guys
this place is of no exit we're in not
going out
oh my dad's gonna save us we're getting
out of here
don't worry i saw i know where kate
landed what that's great
should i tell you a story
it's the story of an orphan girl
from a far away land
who was sent to live
in a mysterious house
[Music]
and what if i were to tell you she
discovered something
magical
[Music]
something
secret
[Music]
would you believe me
[Music]
if you cause me trouble i'll have you
stand away in an instant
[Music]
i knew you were hiding something
this garden it's capable of
extraordinary things
now will you believe in the magic
[Music]
look guys it's carl he's on probation
he's got a baby panda don't mess it up
can i stay at your place for a while no
we make perfect partners forget about it
come on you know you want to
[Music]
mick mc why did you order this i didn't
they're big problems he's so cute
he has to go back to his parents they're
probably worried sick by now calls for a
big adventure pandas live in bamboo
forests far off in the south if we sail
down the river it just might be doable i
can help with the supplies
a noble mission i'm so honored come on
me you're too scared
i'm on a quest to find this baby's
parents want to tag along looks like i
finally found a friend
what are you waiting for come on from a
writer of madagascar
everybody free way ahead of you
[Music]
comes a story of friendship we'll be
like batman and robert like dartanian
and the three musketeers like
[Music]
[Applause]
and family look everyone our baby is all
grown up featuring the voices of drake
bell and paulie shore
yourself you've got a problem the big
trip
[Music]
[Music]
guess it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night
lance sterling a legendary spy who's
always dressed to impress
walter beckett graduated mit at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets i want to test in
the field for example the inflatable hug
kind of a personal protection device
i've been developing
[Music]
this is a vile waste of taxpayer dollars
this is your next objective none of our
agents can get close to him
[Music]
i have something that can help it's
called biodynamic concealment imagine if
i could make you disappear
[Music]
hey lance look at me look at you i can
see my butt and your face at the same
time that is so cool being a pigeon can
make you an even better spy pigeons are
everywhere and nobody notices them
in fact pigeons can see in slow motion
that was tight did anyone else see a um
a pigeon
and pigeons can fly up to 92 miles per
hour don't you throw me off this roof
he'll figure it out
all right kimura starting it's about to
get messy time to go sleepy night night
i miss my hands i gotta stay
we have different skill sets
that's what makes such a great team
wealthy
what happens in the submarine
stays in the submarine
[Music]
stamina
courage
and heart
my business is dogs
he's undersized
he's trouble
well good afternoon
it's untrainable
stop that
what does he bring to the breed
the heart of a survivor
he outran every single one of them
he's not a sled don't
he's a lead dog
what we have in our children is an
epidemic it's a death sentence
they found a cure round trip is 600
miles
you see that storm in the horizon only
one man and one dog can make that run
he's 12 years old he's too old he'll
never make that distance
my guess is we don't find him till the
fall
all right togo time for us to find out
who we are
i always thought he lived for the sled
when all along
[Music]
what he lived for
was me
[Music]
hang up
[Applause]
[Music]
bye